اذا جلسه الحوار اللبناني بيان ختامي
بدا توافقيا خاليا من التفاصيل بحث حاله
يحث على تهدئه سياسيا واعلاميا
ويبدو استخدام السلاح مطالبا لتعزيز سلطه
الدوله والجيش والقضاء
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه من زاويتين
رئيسيتين الدعاه الخلافات السياسيه بين
الاطراف اللبنانيه وتاثيرها على نتائج هذه
الجوله ومدى تداخل البعد الاقليمي خاصه
الملف السوري مع فر الخريطه الداخليه
اللبنانيه
لم يكن سقف التوقعات عاليا قبل بدء جلسه
الحوار الوطني وقد جاء البيان الختامي
معبرا عن ذلك حيث اكتفى بالدعوه لتخفيف
حده الخطاب السياسي والاعلامي وذلك بسبب
حاله التوتر التي تعيشها البلاد على خلفيه
الازمه السوريه وانعكست بوضوح في طرابلس
ويتضح بجلاء ان الملف السوري سيطر على
النقاش رغم انه لم يكن مدرجا على جدول
الاعمال الذي كان مخصصا لبحث سلاح حزب
الله وسلاح المخيمات الفلسطينيه ونزع
السلاح من الافراد في الشارع
عام الفين وثمانيه والديه الموضوعات التي
نوقشت في دوله الحوار السابقه فرضت نفسها
على هذه الجلسه ومعها ذات الاسباب التي
منعت تنفيذها واهمها موضوع الامن في لبنان
والذي تكلفه الان بشكل او باخر احداث
سوريا المجاوره
بدا اعلن بعد الصادر بعد جلسه الحوار
توافقيا خاليا عن الكثير من التفاصيل خاصه
تلك المتعلقه بموضوعات نزع السلاح الذي ت
حوزه بعض الفصائل اللبنانيه كما هو الحال
مع سلاح حزب الله او التعامل مع سلاح
الفلسطينيين داخل و خارج المخيمات والمتفق
عليه ايضا منذ الجوله السابقه او السلاح
المنتشر في انحاء لبنان المختلفه ولكن
الاعلان اكد مواصله دراسه السبل الكفيله
لوضع الاليات تنفيذ قرارات مؤتمرات الحوار
السابقه لم يشر اعلان بعبدا الى التعامل
مع تطورات الاحداث السوريه وانعكاساتها
وان اشار الى ضبط الاوضاع على الحدود مع
سوريا وعدم السماح باقامه منطقه عازله في
لبنان او استخدام البلاد كما مر او مقر او
منطلق بتهريب السلاح والمسلحين مع كفاله
حق التضامن الانساني والتعبير السياسي
والاعلامي لجميع اللبنانيين
وهنا يبدو مخيما على الاعلام شبح احداث
طرابلس الاخيره المواجهات العنيفه التي
جرت فيها بين مؤيد الرئيس السوري
فقط الجبل المحسن معطل العلويين ومؤيدي
الثوره المندلعه ضده منذ مارس العام
الماضي في منطقه باب التبان السنيه الى
جانب تطورات اختطاف احد عشر اللبنانيه
شيعيا في سوريا الشهر الماضي وما حققته من
توترات على صعود الدوله المختلفه
لم يتوقع كثير من المراقبين من جلسه
الحوار اكثر من مصدر وتحدثت الاوساط
الاعلاميه اللبنانيه مبكرا عن عدم
اختلافها عن جولات الحوار السابقه وان
اسهم انعقادها بشكل او باخر في خفض حده
التوتر بين تقاطعات الشارع السياسي
اللبناني باطيافه المختلفه في انتظار
الخامس والعشرين من هذا الشهر
لانعقاد الجلسه المقبله
الينا من بيروت رمزي كنج القيادي في
التيار الوطني الحر
ومعنا ايضا من بيروت شهر الجمهور عضو
ائتلاف الرابع عشر من اذار ابدا معك سيد
اه رمزي بدايه لماذا تاخر استئناف الحوار
الوطني الى هذه اللحظه ونحن نعلم جميعا
بان اخر الجلسه كانت في اواخر 2010
يعني طلع عده امور المنظمه منذ توقف
الحوار بالمرحله الماضيه حتى اليوم كان
لابد من بعض ال المقدمه يا اللي استمعنا
في مقدمه التقرير من حيث التوصيف المذهب
الى المناطق واستجلاب المشاكل اللي عم
بتصير ب محيطنا العربي الى الداخل
اللبناني كان في شعور عند المسؤولين في
الدوله اللبنانيه بانه لا بد من اعاده ان
عقاب طاوله الحوار من اجل تنفيس الاحتقان
الذي بدا يعني اه يغلي في الشارع اللبناني
وشفنا من المظاهر ما يكفي في الاشهر
الاخيره من ناحيه استجلاب الازمات الى
دخلنا اللبناني ونحنا صراحه بغنى عنها اه
اذن اه الظروف الحاليه هي التي فرضت ضروره
العوده الى طاوله الحوار اه الوطني لكن
ماذا عن الخلافات السياسيه ان اردنا ان
نقلب السؤال هل هي كانت السبب وراء تاجيل
الحوار الى هذا الوقت
الخلافات السياسيه لم تتوقف لحظه منذ
انسحاب الجيش السوري من لبنان عام الفين
وخمسه حتى ال حتى اليوم
عذرا عذرا سيد كانت زادت بشكل يعني ملحوظ
جدا في الفتره الاخيره وزاد ايضا التصعيد
الاعلامي بين مختلف الاطراف وذلك ما جاء
ايضا في البيان الختامي اجتماع اليوم
بالضبط يعني هذا ما اه هذا اللي اليوم
شعرنا واستمعنا لالو بالبيان الختامي اللي
صدر عن طاوله الحوار من حيث الدعوه الى
اعاده الهدوء الى حتى الى تصاريح
المسؤوليين والتعبئه المذهبيه والطائفيه
البغيضه ياللي اه انتشرت بالفتره الاخيره
على لسان مسؤولين وعلى لسان النواب
والتدخل في شؤون الاخرين واستجلاب المشاكل
الى الداخل والتقسيم الطائفي والمذهبي
لبعض المناطق ولبعض الشوارع ببعض الاحيان
ول عمليات الخطف يا اللي يا اللي ازدهرت
بالمرحله الاخيره على اساس طائفي
كان لا بد من من اعاده جمع طاوله الحوار
التي تضم مختلف المسؤولين على الساحه
اللبنانيه
لانه وخصوصا ال الشيء الذي اكدوا عليه في
نهايه ال الحوار اليوم الذي دام ثلاث
ساعات هو الت ال التاكيد على انه لبنان
يرفض ان يكون مقرا او ممرا ل اه التدخل في
شؤون الاخرين وارسال هذا العلم والخبر الى
الجامعه العربيه والامم المتحده لحتى الى
حد ما يحيدوا لبنان عن الصراعات القائمه
بالمنطقه على الرغم مما ذكرته هذا البند
تحديدا الاصرار على ان لا يكون لبنان مقرا
او ممرا تحديدا لتهريب السلاح الى سوريا
وغيرها من النقاط
كثيرون توقعوا حتى قبل الحوار بان لا يصدر
عنه اه الشيء الكبير وهو بالفعل ما قرا
بين طياته بانه لم يخرج بتلك القرارات
التي كانت متوقعه وبان البنود التي دعيت
مختلف الاطراف اليها لم تطرح اصلا للنقاش
ولم يتضمنها البيان الختامي
لا بالتاكيد بالتاكيد ليس من الجلسه
الاولى مفترض ان تطرح جميع
المواضيع الخلافيه على طاوله البحث ولكن
ما اكثر عليها اليوم المجتمعون في من
الكفايه ومن الايجابيه ما يكفي لتنفيس
الاحتقان
ال
التخفيض من مستوى الخطاب الطائفي والمذهبي
واه دعم الجيش اللبناني ودعمه بمسؤولياته
الامنيه وبان الغطاء دعم المؤسسات
القضائيه لناحيه التوقيف المطلوبين وعدم
الضغط على المؤسسات القضائيه لاخراجهم تحت
ال اه تحت عده مسميات
وعدم التدخل في شؤون الاخرين عدم استجلاب
الازمه الخارجيه الى لبنان كل ها المواضيع
المهمه التي لا يمكن ان تحل في جلسه واحده
وخصوصا يعني اليوم كان في شيء ملفت انه
الجلسه المقبله هي في خمسه وعشرين حزيران
نامل ان تكون بوتيره متسارعه مختلف
الجلسات يعني اه اه اذن لم تتضمن تضمنت
حسب وجهه نظرك العديد من النقاط فقط اود
هنا الان مشاهدينا الكرام بان السيد شارل
جبور عضو الائتلاف اربعه عشر من اذار
يفترض ان يكون معنا في هذه الحلقه يشاركنا
النقاش يتعذر الى الحد الان لاسباب فنيه
بحثه ان يكون معنا نحاول اصلاح ذلك لكن
نواصل اه الحديث معك سيد اه كانت ذكرت بان
العديد من النقاط قد تم الخروج بها في هذا
البيان ويفترض ان تكون هنالك بالفعل
الجلسه في الخامس والعشرين من الشهر لكن
ما كان لافتا انه لم يتم التطرق البنود
الثلاث التي دعا على اساسها اه الرئيس
اللبناني المجتمعين سلاح حزب الله السلاح
الموجود في المخيمات وحتى السلاح المتواجد
بين الافراد لماذا
جلسه الحوار الماضيه تم الاتفاق على
مناقشه السلاح الفلسطيني خارج المخيمات
وليس داخل المخيمات داخل المخيمات هذا
بيتم يعني يتطلب جلسات الحوار الماضي ولا
في جلسه الحوار
المفترض انه هذا السلاح الفلسطيني داخل
المخيمات
نعم هذا ما قصدته
خارج المخيمات يعني كان تماما
اه كنا نتذكر انه تم الاتفاق على طاوله
الحوار التي بدات قبل حرب تموز في عام
الفين وسته على معالجه السلاح الفلسطيني
خارج المخيمات في ذلك الوقت كان يحضر ال
الجلسات حتى السيد حسن نصر الله ولكن قصه
للحكومات المتعاقبه التي طلق اه يعني حتى
عام الفين وثمانيه لماذا لم يعالج هذا
السلاح خارج المخيمات وخصوصا انه شكلت
احنا
السفير السابق خليل مكون ولم تعلن عن
مضمون لقاءات او كل من تذكر اللقاءات
الشهيره التي حصلت بين الرئيس السابق
للحكومه سعد الحريري و امين عام للجبهه
الشعبيه القياده العامه احمد جبريل في كسر
يتم ولم نعلم ان ما كانت نتيجه ال
الحوارات امام الناحيه السيد حزب الله فهو
مفتوح للمناقشه حتى من قبل طاوله الحوار
التي بدات في عام الفين وسته والتي
استانفت اليوم وهو مطروح دائما على
الطاوله وفي النقاش السياسي وفي المنتديات
كافه وعلى على طاوله على طاوله ال النقاش
دائما السياسي هذا يعني موضوع لا ينتهي في
في جلسه واحده في جلسه واحده اليوم من
المفترض ان يعني جميع الفرقاء يدلو بدلوهم
بهذا الموضوع وبالنهايه ال الهدف الاسمى
من هذا الموضوع هو ليس كيفيه نزع سلاح حزب
الله بقدر اه ايجاد وسيله الدفاع عن لبنان
ضد ال اي هجوم خارجي عليه من قبل اسرائيل
مثل اللي شاهدنا عليهم باكثر من اه من ظرف
في الاربعين سنه الماضيه اما من ناحيه
السلاح المنتشر بين ايدي اللبنانيين
فقد يعني يعني لا يستطيع بعد الان احد ان
يعين الاخر للسلاح الفردي فقد راينا منه
حتى ب ب مستويات مرتفعه جدا ومن نوعيات
عاليه جدا في مناطق كانت مفترض ان تكون
محسوبه على من يطالبون بنزع السلاح الفردي
من اه من من حزب الله
من لديه القدره ايضا على نزع هذا السلاح
وهل فعلا امنيه موجوده لنزع هذا السلاح عن
اللبنانيين كل اللبنانيين
يعني اه
صراحه يعني السلاح الفردي الذي اه سلاح
الفرد ال البسيط الموجود بين ايدي
اللبنانيين حتى قبل ان تندلع ال يعني
الاحداث خمسه وسبعين هو مطلوب الى حد ما
رفع الغطاء او ما يسمى برفع الغطاء
السياسي عن عن حام ليه لانه ما شاهدناه في
الفتره الاخيره مجموعات كبيره محسوبه على
تيار المستقبل وعلى اه وعلى فريق المعارضه
اليوم مع الفريق المعارض للحكومه اليوم
انتشرت بين يعني بين ايديهم وبكميات كبيره
جدا نوعيات مختلفه من السلاح ما لم نشهده
في في حتى في سنوات
ارجو ان تبقى معنا بات جاهزا الجمهور عضو
ائتلاف الرابع عشر من اذار نرحب بك سيد
اه طبعا هذا التاخير الخارج فعلا اه عن
ارادتنا ونسال ولو انه ربما من هذا النقاش
تابعه جلسات الحوار اليوم او جلسه اليوم
تحديدا واعلان بعد الذي صدر عنها
والى اي مدى
فيه بعض الاستجابه مما دعيت من اجله
السلاح منتشر في المدن وغير
سببوا
الله
وكان المشروع على السلاح لانه
القاضي
الجمهوريه والامر الاخر
بالاجتماع المشاركه اربعطاشر
والحكومه
على البلد
لماذا
بانها كان هناك
مثلا وبين من سكت اصلا في هذا الحوار
لماذا اذن التيار المشاركه
في
الحكومه
يعني انت تذكر فقط السلبيات منذ قليل
السيد رمزي اه تحدث ربما نقاط ايجابيه
كثيره تضمنها البيان الختامي انا فقد
نتوقف عند بعضها التزام نهج الحوار
والتهدئه الامنيه تثبيت دعائم الاستقرار
دعم الجيش على الصعيدين المعنوي والمادي
كذلك ضروره ربما التقليل من هذه المناكفات
الاعلاميه بين مختلف القوى لان الوضع في
لبنان كما يرى الكثيرون لا يحتمل اه ربما
ان يدخل في مثل هذه المتاهات وهذه
المناكفات اه الاعلاميه ما رايك في كل هذه
الايجابيات
وقطع
يقول بان
ارجو ان تبقى معنا
سنعود اليك ايضا ان يبقى معنا اه ضيفنا
رمزي كانت اه على كل ننتقل الان الى فاصل
قصير نتابع بعده النقاش للبحث في تاثير
البعد الاقليمي خاصه الملف السوري في
الواقع السياسي الداخلي في لبنان ابقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام في هذه
الحلقه نتحول الى ضيفنا في بيرو السيد
رمزي كنج القيادي في التيار الوطني الحر
سمعت ما ذكره السيد شهر اه بان ربما ما تم
مناقشته في جلسه الحوار هذه لم يتم مناقشه
ربما الصلب المواضيع التي كان يفترض ان
تناقش سلاح حزب الله ومن الواضح ان هناك
فجوه كبيره بين مختلف الاطراف اه السياسيه
كيف انتم تعتقدون بان فعلا كان يفترض ان
يكون هذا الحوار
وبصراحه اكثر خاصه في ظل هذه الظروف
الحاليه الازمه السوريه الجميع يتحدث عنها
لكن تقريبا البيان الختامي من اي ذكر لها
بالطبع
تداعيات الازمه السوريه على الداخل
اللبناني ولكن يعني اه ضيفك الكريم انه اه
يعني طياره السياسي هو الوحيد الذي تغلب
على طاوله الحوار بالوقت اللي فيه فرقاء
متحالفين عضويه مع تيار سياسي كان محاضرين
على طاوله الحوار هلا هني عندهن ازمه
داخليه بين بعضهم من حيث تركيبتنا من حيث
مكوناتها وتراجعوا عن الكثير من الشروط
التي كان وضعوها منذ حوالي الاسبوع العالم
الدخول الى طاوله الحوار هني بيحلوا
المشاكل ومن بين بعضهن ولكن اه في الكثير
من الفرقاء السياسيين في حزب الكتائب التي
رحب بعده انعقاد طاوله الحوار واعتبر انه
هذا
انعقاده ولا حتى في النصوص التي خرج هذا
الحوار لكن في التطبيق في نهايه
اوكي سيدتي سيدتي الكريمه اذا لم يكن هناك
من حوار ماذا يمكن ان يكون هناك حربا
وافتعال المشاكل او توثرات امنيه على
مختلف الاراضي اللبنانيه هل يستطيع الشعب
اللبناني بعد ان يتحمل مشاكل امنيه في بين
فرقاء وبين طوافه بينهما يعني هذا ال بديل
عن الحوار اما من ناحيه سلاح حزب الله
اه يعني ضيفك الكريم يعني لا يجب ان ان ان
ان ننسى انه عقبه الانسحاب السوري من
لبنان كانت طرف المسيحي التي الذي غطى
انذاك سلاح حزب الله في التحالف الرباعي
عندما اخذوا الاكثريه في السلطه منبثقه
بالانتخابات النيابيه بعد انسحاب الجيش
السوري من لبنان في الوقت الذي كان يجب ان
يكون هناك اكثر من مؤتمر
اكثر من مؤتمر واه تاسيس ال اعاده انتاج
السلطه وليس بالشكل الذي حصلت
يعني بوقتها التفاهم والتحالف بين اه بين
تيار السياسه وبين حزب الله وفريق تيار
المستقبل اما الا اذا كانت العبره في
تنفيذ ال المقررات يعني خلينا ن ن طاوله
الحوار يعني ما زالت اه هي كانت متوقفه
تتوافق تماما مع اعلنه اه لبنان الرسمي من
سياسه النائبين ذكرت الضرر الازمه السوريه
هل تعتقدون بان هناك امكانيه فعلا لديكم
رفاهيه درء الازمه اه السوريه وهي قد دخلت
من البوابه الشماليه للبنان ولا احد يعلم
الى اين يمكن ان تصل
لا بالطبع وبالتاكيد يعني اليوم كل
الفرقاء كانوا متواجدين على طاوله الحوار
وهني وافقوا على البيان الختامي الذي يدعو
الى الى تداعيات الازمه السوريه عن ال اه
عن الواقع اللبناني وهيدي فيه مسؤوليه
معنويه
والتزام اتجاه الشعب اللبناني اذا احد ال
الفرقاء اخل بهذا الاتفاق وخصوصا اذا
عادوا الى حمله التجييش التي شاهدناها في
الاشهر الماضيه نوابه وكوادر في منطقه
الشمال او في منطقه عقار واعاده ت بس
الخطاب الطائفي واعاده تشحن الاجواء ضد ال
ضد النظام السوري بدنا نحنا نحنا بالنسبه
لان ال الموقف المعلن هو عدم التدخل في
النزاع القائم بسوريا
وفعلا
النائب ال اه بالنفس عن تداعيات الازمه
السوريه هلا مواقف اعلاميه اه يمكن اه هذا
هذا الشيء مسموح فيه يعني اللي كل الفرقاء
هذا
بموجه دستورنا مسموح في ال ال يعني
المهم انه من المهم ان
مهم انه ما نتحول الى الى تدخل بال بال
بال بال شان العسكري كما شاهدنا ب ب باخره
السلاح التي كانت قادمه يعني ودخلت
الاراضي اللبنانيه
فيما بقي معنا من الوقت قرابه دقيقتين فقط
واتحول ب اه السؤال للسيد اه شهر سيد شارل
تداخل البعض الاقليمي تحديدا الازمه
السوريه كيف تلقي بظلالها على الداخل
اللبناني وما الذي يفترض فعليا على الطبقه
السياسيه وما يقع على عاتقها من المسؤوليه
لتجنيد اه لبنان ويلات ما يمكن ان تنعكس
لهذه الازمه
يعني الموضوع تحكم لبنان
قوى اربعطاش اذار حتى الاجور المسيحي
من من
من ال من من من عن سابق تصور وتصميم اه
الوفاق لبنان بالمحور السوري الايراني
تحديد مستحيل
استمرار حزب الله على
المسمى نحن ممانعه وما يحصل تعديل
الاسف بلبنان الحرب الاهليه في لبنان
بالتاكيد انه لبنان
هذه القوى السياسيه
منع هذه الازمات انه
ليست موجوده الدوله اللبنانيه الدوله
اللبنانيه الوحيده التي
من ضمن المؤسسات
الدوله غير قابله
الله في لبنان
المحور الممانعه
فريق
اشعال الحرب
علما انه
من الدوله اللبنانيه
السوريه الى لبنان
بوضع القرار بالدوله اللبنانيه
السياسي
ان يكون قرارهم قرار
على لبنان
نشكر ضيفنا رمزي كنج جزيل الشكر القيادي
في التيار الوطني الحر بهذا
الخبر باذن الله قراءه جديده